okay what's up everyone we are at the
blockchain economic forum we are now
with Irene E Schlosser
hello hi how are you thank you for
coming out of the show thank you so much
for having me I greatly appreciate it so
you are with international blockchain
investments been there now ventures yep
ibi ventures and i was just listening to
a panel you were on and it was amazing
seeing six women on the panel it was a
blast
absolutely I am in love with seeing
women in high positions in technology
I'm like let's get more of that in the
world as soon as possible we rarely have
it to be honest it's it's something that
you really only see we've only seen it
really in the last year and thankfully
it's been starting to grow and
especially it's really indicative of
what the quality of the panel that we
had today the women alongside me were
fantastic so it was great - great to be
speaking with them yeah we've had tests
and radhika on the show before and women
in technology international just
happened we were doing interviews there
you should totally come next year oh I
need to make sure you know yeah
absolutely
because we also need some we needed some
women in blockchain that where I'm at
witty as well so ok now this is the
decentralization movement yes and
there's a lot of people that are like I
want to be part of the decentralization
movement it like gives people so much
meaning and purpose to try and be a part
of this maybe the first question before
we talk about kind of like you know your
background is in invest investment
investment banking morgan stanley or JP
Morgan where is it Morgan Stanley and
then then you went into some AI and food
which is really interesting as well so
maybe over the years as you became more
aware of decentralization what kind of
like drew you to it in the first place
and also like what were your earlier
kind of thoughts about it before like
let's talk about before today before the
present sure so I think you know I got
into blockchain in the same way that I
most people I know got in
through initially just getting exposed
to cryptocurrencies and I think what
made decentralization more palpable for
us was understanding how smart contracts
work and then it was basically mind
blowing any sense that you could really
apply the the process of how a
decentralized block Taner decentralized
ledger more specifically could be
applied to many different industries and
so I probably started to move out of any
type of focus on more cryptocurrencies
and much more on how the technology
could be disrupting essentially how the
world is working as well as people's
philosophies and it's interesting that
you mentioned you know the
decentralisation movement because I
think there's different factions of it
which is it's extremely interesting to
watch how it unfolds so there you have
the very you know hard-line believers
and that everything should be
decentralized and I think one of the it
was one of the biggest lessons for me
was realizing with a lot of these very
intense debates on decentralized
governance that you know there's a lot
of right now we've captured data on
humans that are essentially what we see
and what we click we really haven't
captured human behavior to understand
what actually drives the dynamics and
this also brings in a little bit of you
know how effective is artificial
intelligence as well but from the
blockchain side in terms of building in
decentralized governance I started
getting much more into the school of
thought that that was too extreme not
because I don't believe that it's
possible but I don't think I think we're
probably around 8 to 10 years away of
collecting enough data on that and so I
started really actually diving down the
dot the rabbit hole of neuroscience oh
wow yeah but but more I think that even
just neuroscience is not really
capturing the entire picture I think
it's it's gathering all of the
biomarkers and as well as the
qualitative data of what people truly
experience and how do you integrate that
into teams and so that's where into
teams well with this decentralized
governance yeah that kind of the scary
part of decentralized governance was
that essentially you were allowing the
code to dictate what your performance
was and what the result of each action
was and a lot of situations where teams
are performing it's great
and so how people are managed how
returns are managed how you know
decentralize applications are managed in
a way because it's not just the code
right to be able to scale something to a
mass market you need to be able to
communicate it effectively and yes that
might result in you know great
advertising but it's really just
packaging it in a way and how do we
actually incentivize humans to want to
use it and to the end to essentially
adopt the technology and that's
something that I don't think a
decentralized team can do and
essentially a team can't necessarily be
motivated in the right way yet because
we don't have enough data on how teams
and companies and generally
organizations work I was not expecting
you to do jump into understanding human
behavior with blockchain technology and
and understanding the brain and how you
know psychology and how inner workplace
dynamics and even families and
relationships all that stuff because
that is something that people don't talk
about that often here in
decentralization space so okay cool so
so but how did that initially become
your draw it really became like a almost
like a passion project on the side of
investing on the venture capital side
because you know most venture capital
firms will tell you that they're really
investing in the team and so when you
look at a lot of these blockchain
projects which are decentralized I mean
it's from a community of developers that
you don't necessarily they're all over
the world there's not necessarily a
strict organizational approach to it and
at the bottom line it's not it's not
just the code building a business or an
infrastructure and expanding it to a
mass market really requires a
multidisciplinary approach and so the
diversity of teams is something that I
think we haven't really been able to
dice and decentralize yet and so it's
kind of it's a natural effect of the
conversations you have when it's a team
of engineers and they're saying yeah you
know we've got another thousand
engineers and we're asking well who's
doing the marketing or how are you brain
how are you communicating this an
audience how does blockchain or
decentralized technologies disrupt the
world and they haven't really I think
i reticulated a great answer yet but i
think we're close okay so so that would
very deep dive and it's very exciting
dive because i think understanding how
to maximize interpersonal dynamics is
going to help us maximize our potential
so I think that's that's very important
and it's very interesting that you went
there I wasn't expecting that was very
cool
um and let's um let's we'll unpack that
a little more as we go it seems as
though you are now is this is the
International blockchain investment
ventures ibi Ventris is that fund it is
a fun we are focused in more of the
short term on how we can essentially
invest in companies that have fantastic
technology and how that technology can
be integrated or sold to different
enterprises and I think that's
definitely the lowest hanging fruit in
the sense that you know most companies
desperately need an infrastructure
upgrade and there are situations where
decentralized technologies make sense
and maybe it's like a semi-private
blockchain or it's a blockchain that is
public but there's enough encryption and
security to get enterprises comfortable
in a more efficient process but there's
also a lot of enterprise technologies
that need to be upgraded without
blockchain they literally just need you
know centralized cloud systems
essentially or they don't necessarily
need it to be you know set up with a
group of another three hundred
organizations or limitless number of
organizations and I think that's
identifying the difference of what where
blockchain is necessary and where it can
add a lot of value and where it's not
necessary at this point in time and
another technology might just be
sufficient that's that's really
important to to bring up think
everybody's trying to blockchain
everything and decentralize everything
and maybe other technologies are better
used for now in that space instead and I
guess this is a question that we asked
and I think it'd be interesting ask you
what do you think shouldn't be
decentralized interesting so I think
you know there's a lot of companies that
they already have the data they already
have the reach and there are certain
aspects of their platforms that can be
decentralized and and one thing you know
I would love to see decentralize would
be something like a participation and
music on Spotify I would love to get
paid for in tokens for the quality of
the playlists that I'm creating and
essentially I'm allowing Spotify as AI
to become better by providing that data
obviously can be provided with other
music platforms as well one thing I
would say that it wouldn't make sense to
necessarily put on blockchain would
definitely be at the moment where we
need very I would say high speed
processing systems and sometimes maybe
it's a gradual switch where you're
starting off with something that's more
centralized because you can ensure the
speed and the and the and the quality
and as the decentralized network grows
larger you can start to replace it I
think that's where just making a full
hard split - and changing to block
changes off the bat it might not make
sense it definitely needs to be more of
a gradual shift than trying to just get
everyone on blockchain at once because
it won't be fast we're gonna be looking
at a lot of crashes and and not and also
that you know the protocols and what's
being built we really need to get a
solid infrastructure in place first
before everything starts moving to
blockchain so with the best processing
speeds that are available today those
remaining centralized to complete the
tasks that they need to do for now and
then you're looking at the greatest
impact that you can make with investing
and does that does that kind of
piggyback on your initial point about
human behavior is that kind of where
you're very focused with your people so
we're four people on the team we're
targeting about 250 million dollar raise
we're in the process actually we already
are about at our first 50 million in
commitments Congrats thank you it's been
a fun process so yeah and I think you
know with the fund it's really just
understanding what phases are going to
come first and trying to find
we're the largest impact in disruption
will happen and so where I think I would
expect to come obviously we were already
saying you know the enterprise is
probably coming first because it's the
easiest to sell to a smaller a smaller
amount of parties versus trying to mass
market this and also the enterprise are
actually asking for it so the consumers
they don't it's almost like when the
first you know Apple iPod came out we
didn't know that we needed an mp3 player
that was the size of an iPod so it's
really a blockchain is coming and
helping consumers in a way that they
don't even know that they need the
problem solved yet and I think so for
example one thing that I I was I was
explaining to a friend of mine was you
know she's very focused on where her
food is sourced and what ingredients are
in it and I was explaining how
blockchain can solve that and she goes
really
that's what blockchain can solved for me
I go yeah and and it's it's that's
hasn't really been communicated and it's
gonna take a lot more marketing effort
and more of a wider industry approach on
the technology side to get people
comfortable with how blockchain can make
their their lives easier and so I think
that's a little bit later stage but
we're already looking for the right
teams to do that come a little more
center shot so okay so there it's easier
to get into blockchain with an
enterprise and because it seems as
though corporations organizations are
more quickly able to adapt in
decentralization technologies into their
organization to maximize the revenue
maximize their transparency max my
supply chain all these different types
things we're asked for individuals is
not not only not as lucrative but it's
also more difficult to get like 10,000
people to sign up for something that is
to get one organization that supports
10,000 people to sign up so what
investments are you making into the
blockchain Enterprise speech sure so
we're definitely looking at traceability
so I spent actually the weekend with a
group who's looking at building it into
the auto automobile manufacturing parts
systems and which is actually it's very
interesting because you have a market
right now which is very fragmented by
different suppliers
and of the automobile parts if one
company is at capacity they'll often
overload an outsourced type of
production to competitors and so and
then it's basically overlay that with
the fact that recalls happen and so what
happens when a recall happens obviously
you have regulators getting involved the
parts are traced back to the original
manufacturer and so they need to know
exactly where those parts came from what
the timestamp was what the parameters
were in terms of the how the process was
how the part was produced whether it was
heat or you know what type of exposure
did that part have and then identifying
what other parts would be similar and
that's something where blockchain can
solve that especially a private
blockchain and what's really important
there is the fact that the big boundary
the entry the barrier to entry is the
fact that they're suppliers and
competitors don't want to share
information and so there's this
asymmetry between the groups of them
where they need to know that the
blockchain will ensure that the
information and data is only available
to groups that are on a need-to-know
basis whether it's regulators access or
words yeah exactly it's access control a
higher encryption and so the biggest
barrier for enterprises is making sure
that they're comfortable with the
privacy and the encryption and security
of that data because normally in a
centralized manner they're very
comfortable with a decentralized manner
much less so yeah even even in though in
reality that decentralized way might
even be way more secure yeah they don't
they can't verify that and we were
speaking with people who are not
necessarily developers and they're not
as particularly blockchain developers
they need to it's it's a bigger barrier
to get comfortable there all right how
about in this example are you then
funding the enterprise software that's
enabling the steel company to have their
steel be passed on to the automotive
manufacturers or their aluminum carbon
fiber or are we talking about the
automotive manufacturer is is the one
that's taking the enterprise software
that you're funding and then putting all
the different parts that they receive
from the main
it's really it's a multi party approach
and so you really need to get the entire
supply chain involved and that's why and
the other issue is that the individual
companies which would love to do it
themselves the other companies won't
trust them to do it so it either needs
to be something spun off or quarantined
and has nothing to do with one entity
and it's more of an independent entity
that's coming in providing a
decentralized service where all
participants are incentivized to
participate essentially all parties are
incentivized to participate
does that make sense yeah definitely
now that's one of many examples now
maybe give us another relatable example
sure
so another relatable example would be
traceability of food origins so now
you're making an investment here already
so we're in the part we're looking at
we're in due diligence process with a
few types of these companies yeah and so
another one is food traceability which
they're initially the technology that
they're applying it for is essentially
high quality or let's say European Union
type protected foods which are specific
and the which might be wine it might be
champagne it might be you know for
example you can only have feta that's in
Greece anywhere outside of Greece cannot
call it feta and so when you go abroad
I'm like trying to say it in a way that
no one else can understand because I'm
good yeah I heard it this is also
similar for like caviar and kool-aid
caviar exactly exactly and so I think
one of the battles that they're the one
that they're tackling is that they go
these guys are from specifically from
Italy and so they were seeing that in
China there's a lot of counterfeit or
not just China but you know many
countries around the world there's a lot
of counterfeit products that say this is
from Italy but they don't actually it's
not truly from Italy and so traceability
to country of origin would be their
initial lowest hanging fruit to tackle
in food but it's also important in parts
even commodities you know if you're
looking at where from a geopolitical
perspective of being able to trace where
oil is coming from
it's extremely important and as well to
the you know whether it's the United
States infrastructure or just general
geopolitics and so that's something that
blockchain can definitely solve and I
think especially when you have the
entrepreneurs or the developers that are
very focused on the technology you know
they've looked at it and said okay we
can do it with food first because we
already have an existing business and
the food space and so it's a it's an
easy step in as a VC we're looking at it
and saying okay where else can this
technology be easily applied and
packaged yeah and that's why you picked
original equipment manufacturing that's
why you picked food traceability
he's very relatable exactly if you break
down blocked and I think there's
probably four areas that we're looking
at the first which I've really been
getting into his identity and it can be
identity of things meaning you know the
food the auto parts etc it can be
identity of people which is the their
driver's license their medical records
etc and that's all kind of this similar
technologies in terms of the blockchain
decentralize support but it's applied to
different industry cases and use cases
and then you have so identity being the
first one the second being
incentivization and so that's where you
can have a lot of people being paid with
utility tokens and incentivize to
participate in a platform in a way where
they're incentivized not to cheat and to
provide the best value to that platform
there's a few use cases there but I
think that's where you know the etherium
mining and a lot of the utility tokens
are essentially making sorry utility
tokens built on that or making more
sense and also in the gaming space as
well and then you have the custodial
issue so what happens where the identity
needs to get transferred and that's
something that there's quite a few
groups trying to tackle I think it's in
more of the early stages and the last
portion is security so I think
blockchain can do a lot with security
and encryption it's not something that
we've particularly dope into at ivi
ventures yet we're much more on the
traceability side and an incentivization
I like your your pillars your break
downs great and I think that having
kind of like an philosophical or an
ethical breakdown like that both the one
that understands the economy and
understands the way things are moving
but also one that's based in values or
ethics around like trying to do it for
the purpose of making the world better
is really important along the way okay
so I would normally also ask you know
what are you most looking forward to but
it seems like you already answer that
quite a lot I'm looking forward to my
vacation at some point I'm kidding
you said you go to Greece so much no I
you know I used to I grew up going to
Greece all the time and then
investment-banking I still had an
element of vacation and then after being
an entrepreneur you just you realize
that you love working so much so much so
much that you just forget okay and on
all of your extra expenses are like oh I
have extra dollars this month I can spy
I can get another developer to do more
for me some new features new teammates
this year I vowed to myself that well
everyone else is taking vacation in
August I will also be taking vacation in
August that is the plan that's a good
that's a good vow it's important to be
able to balance in a little bit of
travel into life but you're totally
right though entrepreneurs end up loving
what they do so much I think it's almost
to their demise and in many cases so I I
know I went through it most
entrepreneurs that I know went through
it where you just get into this deep
depression where you're not everyone's
in deep depression but I mean your
self-identity is so closely tied to your
business that you forget that you exist
if that business doesn't exist and so
finding that balance for me actually it
was do I even exist if this channel
doesn't exist just so closely tied to it
and for me it was just really finding
hobbies and so actually I started DJing
like for private like my just my friends
sorry my friends and at home and yeah I
mean I'm the I'm the crazy person at
DJ's my own birthday but music was
really general yeah my music was really
my balance out of all of this okay I
have a question that we like to ask on
the show a lot it seems as though wealth
inequality to be exact exacerbated by
exponential technology and the poor
people in the world they're slowly
coming up meanwhile the top were just
exploding in wealth what do you think's
can have
often quality that's tough to be honest
I think the entire ICO space was driven
by that and I know I alongside many
other female entrepreneurs that I've
spoken with have all faced kind of and
it's not just women it's people that are
from a different background we've faced
a huge barrier to getting first time
founder funding and I think that's
something where you know most investors
around the u.s. are generally follow-on
investors and so who are the ones that
take the lead and take the risk on an
entrepreneur they're generally in a very
small ecosystem and they invest in a
very small group of individuals and so
you know myself coming from an
investment banking background and it's
Morgan Stanley and I've worked on sixty
billion dollars worth of deals it was
not still part of that Network and they
were saying you know what do you think
you're an investment banker and you can
do a tech startup and you know I had
seen I had a much more experience than a
18 year old or a 19 year old who might
be a genius but they hadn't lived
through enough life and so I think the
balance out of who people are investing
in as first-time intrapreneurs I do see
that changing and I think it's for the
better and that that will probably also
drive the the shift from the you know
the explosive point zero zero one
percent of growth to more of the wider
minting of millionaires so you know I
think it was an interesting phrase I
heard lately was Fiat billionaire or
crypto billionaire and it was it was
literally a question asked but I think
the crypto billionaire speaks to the
fact that there are people that are
coming from non-traditional backgrounds
and places that you wouldn't have
expected normally yeah that and the way
that you answered the question I don't
think we've had answered in quite that
way yet on the show that there's a
massive potential for funding to be
given to first-time entrepreneurs that
are you that are usually passed on
because of the just a massive amount of
different epic technologies that are
going on in different places in the
world getting involved so it's actually
interesting enough could help uplift the
low SES middle SES faster first-time
entrepreneurs get funded more okay
a couple power/power around questions do
you think we're alone in the cosmos no
do you want power around anyone yeah I
expand a little bit I think that would
be extremely egotistical the human race
to think that we were the only ones out
here and then do you think there are
advanced civilizations that are roaming
out there or what do you think well
that's an interesting question you know
I I try not to form opinions on things I
can't prove I just that's why I said
think yeah I can think you'll imagine I
would imagine it's still an opinion I
would I would think that there is
because we're just kind of a speck of
dot in the universe and so it would
really be statistically impossible for
there not to be you also feel like
you're a speck of dot as well like you
know when you like really tune into your
heart and your mind and your body and
everything do you feel like a speck or
do you feel like a divine creature like
no I definitely feel like a speck and
I'm happy feeling like a speck do you
balance that out with like the divinity
as well though I think everyone might be
is like a everyone is a divine speck
that's what I was a divine speck is
awesome all right I'll go with that
do you think there is a designer to the
universe that's an interesting question
I think everyone has their own opinion
of some type of force that you know
depending on how you culturally look at
it it could be some cultures which
happen to be more individual focus will
view it as an individual other cultures
will view it as something that's more of
a collective combined let's say source
of energy power
I think whatever makes people kind of
reach a state of peace and they're happy
with imbalanced that's probably where
yeah to each his own is probably my my
opinion there but yes what do you
think's the most beautiful thing in the
world
mmm that's tough because it's really
experiences so it's not really a thing I
would say what experiences are the most
beautiful friends family yeah I I mean
that's very difficult to define because
it's it really just depends on what the
situation is and it's usually the
experience that you don't expect I would
say mmm or a memory that you realize was
valuable or that was just a unique it
was such a unique moment that it would
never happen again and you realize it
much later in time that's probably the
most beautiful because you're it is what
it is and it's not mm-hmm you give it
what coming back so it's almost
beautiful because of its scarcity yeah
and you in a lot of the time we give
experiences no love we just say uh
whatever and then later on like a couple
months or years later or something we're
like whoa that was so amazing it helps
me out so much
and then like venue meeting myself was
the worst experience it's usually about
being the best I love that one yeah
that's actually been the most beautiful
things I've experienced when it was
something that I thought was just and it
was truly so much pain but then you end
up being just so thankful for it so I
think that's yeah that's probably the
most beautiful experiences in life
yeah I've been starting to talk more
about how I went to jail and like you
know being being there like thinking
about it over and over again it was just
like such a her and you know but like
really quickly I started being like [ __ ]
that was amazing like I learned so much
it helped me so much with who I am today
what I know today and especially how
like you we just want to help people
that are that have that have made
mistakes you know
because everyone makes mistakes everyone
makes mistakes so and it's just yeah I
mean I don't think there's not yeah I
don't really believe in mistakes even
existing I think there yeah there's some
people that do things that are
legitimately wrong but in terms of like
mistakes it shouldn't stop people from
doing what they what up what learning on
that mistake and then improving upon it
so yeah I'm really happy that our
converse
shree ended up going in like a couple
cool directions along the block she's
bondsman's around yeah that was that was
super fun thank you for coming on to the
show greatly appreciate it everybody if
you guys had a good time please make
sure Welch I will put the link in the
bio okay we'll put the link in the links
in the bio please check out the links
also like comment subscribe also share
the concert other people go tell to
people about what you learned today
they'll tell to people and we'll keep
going
join us on patreon sir and keep doing
cool things like coming to the Box chain
economic format interviewing really
smart people woo thank you yes you're so
welcome and thanks for tuning in
everyone